why can't we just sanction sydney powell
to stop her from filing meritless
lawsuits
that's the question that i've gotten
from so many different people and the
answer is
actually yes generally there is a
procedure to sanction lawyers
called rule 11 after the federal rules
of civil procedure rule 11.
but the problem is it's cumbersome and
judges like other lawyers don't like to
sanction
lawyers why it's the same reason that
sharks don't like to bite other sharks
professional courtesy and also the fear
that if you bite someone else they might
bite you eventually but
as it turns out one defendant is willing
to go to the mat against
sydney powell lawyers for the city of
detroit have filed a rule 11 motion for
sanctions against sydney powell and her
team of craconologists
it might be one step in getting sydney
powell to take a step back before she
files the next meritless elections
lawsuit please subscribe to the channel
i'm going to try this out see if i can
do a daily eagle every weekday
and as always i'll see you in court